Nun, ich denke, wir stehen am Anfang von
etwas, ob es eine Wiederholung dessen ist,
was wir zuvor gesehen haben, oder ob
es etwas anderes ist, das wir noch
herausfinden müssen
Seite kann ich mir vorstellen, dass ohne offene
Kämpfe zwischen den beiden Prinzipien
die Definition eines Kalten Krieges erfüllt wäre,
aber in den 1960er, 70er und 80er Jahren hatten Sie
wirklich eine bipolare Welt, und jetzt haben Sie auch die
Position Chinas, Sie haben auch
viel mehr Einfluss  und da
fähige Regionalmächte so wird die Situation
auch anders aussehen Ich sage nicht es
wird schöner aussehen aber es wird
anders aussehen Ich widme Wodka Scheitern eines
Michelin Sterns von Einstein hören wir
von einem Einkommen als Garn ein lebenswichtiges Hin und
Konflikt lernen  Wie die Menschen darüber nachdenken,
ob dies ein sofortiges Opfer nach dem
Anblick anderer ist, tut
es mir leid, dass die Geschichte hier
beendet ist  waren fertig
Abwesenheit Ende der Conan über Matisse Buffin
Laban auf dem höchsten neueren das ist, wo
in ist absolut auf Muffin in Berkeley
Muffin war ein niedriger pH-Wert widersteht dem meisten Geld, das
er bereitwillig wieder
anfing  gleiten hizmet mag es
so urlaub auf opiat widerstehen osmanischer
shan shan war patatas weniger weniger
fischkarton der lufthanseatenentführer naropa oder
offenheit regia heiß
am meisten kann man sagen le sang es ist
kein glückliches bild und es ist ein bild
das sagt wir brauchen mehr kooperation
Um diese Probleme zu lösen, müssen die Regierungen mehr denn je
außerhalb ihrer Komfortzone zusammenarbeiten, und wir
haben diesen größeren denn je Bedarf an
Zusammenarbeit zu einer Zeit, in der leider
und ich hoffe, dass dies nur kurzfristig ist, der
Appetit auf Zusammenarbeit nachzulassen scheint